[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to
with the x-men fox franchise finally
wrapped up due to dark phoenix
we can now close the lid on the
franchise and make sense of its rather
messy timeline
throughout this video i'll be making
sense of the x-men movies to let you
know not only how best to watch the
films
but also to explain how they work
coherently this is full spoilers ahead
so if you haven't seen dark phoenix yet
and don't want major elements of that
movie room for yourself
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way i just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video
i hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of the
x-men movie timeline
our timeline begins back in ancient
egypt with apocalypse being put into
hibernation after having his
consciousness transferred to an immortal
this is one of the only fixed points in
the timeline that is unaffected by the
time travel that takes place later
and can be cited as the birth of mutants
from here on our predominantly be
viewing the timeline from the
perspective of wolverine
as he is the only way to really make
sense of everything
and he's also by far the best character
in the franchise
sorry quicksilver anyway we travel to
the 1800s for the next major event
which is the birth of wolverine and his
stepbrother sabertooth
together they journey through many of
the major wars throughout the past
couple of centuries
this includes world war ii most notably
the holocaust in which magneto was
created
also during this period wolverine
becomes a prisoner of war at his
japanese pow camp
and he witnesses the bombing of
hiroshima and this ties into the
timeline later
in the 1960s professor x and magneto
meet for the first time
attempt to recruit wolverine and though
they fail they still create the x-men
whilst mystique is originally charles
friend she eventually sides with magneto
which explains her allegiances later in
the run after first class we go to the
1970s and wolverine
becomes a part of the weapon x program
and during this period
charles loses his way slightly similar
to what we saw in days of future past
however
wolverine is not there to rehabilitate
him and thus this takes slightly longer
it's also during this time that mystique
murders bolivar trask
and sets in motion events that will have
massive ramifications
we then jump to our first film in the
franchise x-men from the year 2000
in this we follow wolverine who has
amnesia as he discovers the group and
decides to join them
the events of x2 and x-men the last
stand
play out and wolverine ends up killing
jean grey professor x is seemingly
killed in the film too
however he manages to transfer his
consciousness to another body and thus
is able to live on
logan racked with guilt shuts himself
off from the rest of the world but is
eventually called to japan for the
events of the film the wolverine
at the end of that movie he's recruited
by magneto and professor x to stop the
rise of the sentinels
which ties into our next film with
mutants and mankind left on the brink of
extinction
due to the rise of the sentinel certain
motion when mystique murdered
bolovatrask
wolverine travels back in time to the
1970s and stops this event from
happening
and thus in days of future past a new
timeline is created
at the end of that film mystique
disguised as william striker pulls
wolverine from the river and whilst this
stops the weapon x procedure from
happening in the 1970s it merely delays
it to the 1980s which is when the next
movie
x-men apocalypse takes place as things
have been slightly shifted in this new
timeline
moira mctaggart now discovers apocalypse
and accidentally awakens him
which sets in motion the chain of events
in this movie this plays out like normal
and wolverine is set loose in the weapon
x compound
thus allowing him to still join the
x-men in the early 2000s
dark phoenix follows in a decade after
this and as the titular events happen
here and not at the same time as they
did in the last stand
jean is not killed by wolverine a
phoenix impression can be seen in the
sky at the end of the film which allows
for her reappearance later in the new
timeline
thus she is alive mystique however does
die in the film which is why she doesn't
appear later on which i'll get into when
we talk about the ending scene of days
of future past
from here the events have been pretty
similar to the original x-men trilogy
though some events have been nudged
slightly so it's not all
exactly the same but it continues
roughly how it did
until we get to the end scene of days of
future past in which wolverine wakes up
in an altered timeline having saved the
world this explains why when he walks
through the mansion he sees gene but not
mystique and this
lines up with their fate in dark phoenix
as gene wasn't killed but mistake was
deadpool 1 and 2 happened roughly around
this time but the next major event
doesn't take place until logan
during his period professor x
accidentally killed all of the mutants
at his mansion
and he caliban and wilby are some of the
only few that remain due to the genetic
extinction that was carried out by dr
rice
whilst wolverine says in this movie when
looking at x-men comics that the events
did not happen the way that they were
portrayed in the books
you have to remember that this is
because he only has memories from the
original timeline
thus when he changed things and nudged
the big moments slightly
they would seemingly happen differently
for him in the comic books
and thus not line up with his memories
logan dies at the end of the film and we
watch as a new group of mutants go out
to carve their own destiny
thus ending the timeline and that's
pretty much how i view the x-men movies
happening and how the timeline makes
sense
obviously there's some unavoidable
inconsistencies like emma frost
but on the whole i think this works and
explains a lot of the plot holes
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on my take of the events and if you
agree or disagree with me
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my ending explained breakdown of
dark phoenix which will be linked after
this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you